welcome to this video against em Western
let's see what did i do this anyway okay
it was one another case where I played
quickly and then thought really anyway
yeah this is a line that I really need
to check 93 it's it's getting more and
more um popular and i have to say that
this 6525 line that something that i
only recently considered to play when i
was thinking about playing the chairman
of it term it was one of the lines that
came to my attentions came to my
attention and it's something that i
absolutely have to learn better because
so i struggle with the c3 sicilian in
the sun and this version and it's and
it's pretty if it's it's it's a bit it's
more dangerous than than other then
other versions of the c32 sign simply
because there are ya this this features
with 93 this is some it's not easy to
handle for black so 85 it goes with this
so maybe here
you
interesting hmm yeah I wonder if it's an
idea to just take on f3 the night might
have a future ani 5c form difficult okay
that was my idea I getting that counter
play against be too quickly really not
easy to easy to say if there is an there
is a valid strategy or not
no my my control over the D file is kind
of interesting so kind of interesting at
sounds Viet is some is some is worth
it's worth something it's probably a
better way to phrase it 95 maybe my echo
he's going clear queenie 03 anyway
maybe I should have played each five for
each for something I know I mean I'm
okay here i'm pretty sure about that but
i'm not so easy to find some way forward
if there is maybe it is just nothing
that I can do
okay i can i can never really take on on
b7 of our play Queen Queen somewhere
check but I think this is this is
totally ok
Queen over there to age 8 22 well that's
interesting yeah I have to do it anyway
it wasn't a very practical decision so
it's not even going in there so what is
this idea okay let's just do what I
wanted to do anyway it takes to see
three Pawn
if I can take beef c3 oh wow didn't
expect that move seems a bit bit passive
at least at first glance i really hope
i'm not doing one of my camy cards are
ideas just looks normal to gain that
space so he's going way out to see 60 k
threatening rock t 1 group c 5 rookie
one is not possible I mean I don't
believe it okay now i can do a couple of
things quincy 3 is one of them let's do
that and look on the second rank
that's a tense position all of a sudden
roof g7 probably king d aid double
attacking time morning I can check check
do this now ok check could be six and
I'm blocking you you shall not pass is
that from Lord of the Rings I think it
is f5 or and this is also more 495 it's
95 not puzzle King e5 nope ya nah I
shouldn't have done that then stupid
don't tell me I'm screwing this up that
would be heartbreaking I could have just
one that by normal means that end game
check
now we're starting to play for some
tricks check check check wow wow what a
wild game check check check mate Wow
whoo Gavin and I just ed sometimes I was
completely completely unnecessary here
to do something fancy can I just voice
that not so using you that he wins that
pawn now maybe maybe I was tempted by 93
but that's yes Bishop c4 amazing so what
was my I mean that that must be right
him or not I mean I was quite clearly
tempted by that Brooke f2 stuff check
check check
the computer wants to go to g7 yeah
probably to have Knight f6 under some
circumstances hm engine gifts gives the
draw all the way now it know why this
better which is not very surprising but
yeah he allowed my opponents lots of
activity all of the Sun now you can
analyze that forever if you want very
complicated engine is on equal which is
probably right here check it will
calculate correctly here b5 here here he
check and now he's losing he has to go
here which which is a draw check this
this this be 792 check I'm sorry how is
this a draw and it says set it wrong yae
to a central scare each was the draw
takes takes takes is this yes amazing
amazing and it's just about a draw wow
wow wow that was little a funky end game
was there something else it was
interesting all of a son from a somewhat
yeah not very spectacular position check
and here then I invaded but it seemed
nothing much what's happening here now I
know g4s given by the computer yeah
maybe this is strong mayor looking at
that square I'd only planning rooty toot
hmm that is possible the engine gives
this which is kind of funny
it's not easy to find and now I look 25
allowing this that's very difficult to
see this kind of nu n term it gives
equal I wonder why once the sequel isn't
that better for black I am maybe there
are just some check oops no the computer
will give equal but if you are human
player just left some job on your hand
to find this this kind of it's perpetual
there well tough tough game thanks for
watching